ED GLAESER: If you are an American and you don't happen to live in Washington DC,
you probably don't think a lot about the connection between your city and
national political power.
The shape of your city is the result largely of the private sector and
modest local government, maybe with a few dollars of aid from elsewhere.
But if you leave the US and take a trip to Paris,
to Rome, to Tokyo, you will see the impact of imperial power all around you.
Napoleonic heritage is visible everywhere in Paris.
From street names commemorating Napoleonic victories, to the Arc de Triomphe,
to the broad boulevards built by Baron Haussmann at the behest of Napoleon III.
The British Empire was once the greatest the globe has ever seen, and
its legacy remains in London.
From the Palace of Westminster to the former hunting grounds of Henry VIII,
Hyde Park.
In the developing world, power shapes urban growth even more completely.
Beijing is incomprehensible, except as the capital of a mighty state.
Delhi's upward trajectory owes much to the favor and
autonomy it has received as India's capital region.
Buenos Aires, Mexico City, Cairo, all of these great world cities are,
above all, political.
So if you are an American, this section will hopefully help you to understand
the unusually nonpolitical nature of large US cities,
which reflect decisions made by both the nation and
the states to locate political capitals away from large population centers.
This section may also help you to understand the positive and
negative consequences of the US and Canadian and Australian and
Brazilian separation of population and power.
If you&#39;re not an American and you live in a large city that happens
also to be a political capital, then this section will hopefully help you to
understand how your city fits into the long tradition of imperial cities.
Your city probably has great monuments, leaders like to leave a legacy in stone.
But also disfunctionalities, like boulevards that may be too broad and
buildings kept artificially low to preserve sight lines.
Power likes to impress more than to enable.
But no matter where you are, you need to understand the role of political power to
understand the past and future of our urban world.
Because so
many of the world's greatest cities have been shaped by the power of their nations.